c'est une courbe qui fait la fierté du
premier ministre benyamin nétanyahou
près de 50 % des israéliens ont déjà
reçu une première dose de vaccin contre
le coït 19
un chiffre impressionnant mais qui ne
suffit visiblement pas aux autorités la
knesset le parlement de l'état hébreu
vient de valider une loi permettant aux
ministères de la santé de transmettre
les noms adresses et coordonnées
téléphoniques des personnes non
vaccinées à d'autres institutions
objectif affiché encourager la
vaccination auprès des plus réfractaires
nous élus par le peuple pour essayer
d'améliorer leur qualité de vie devons
prendre des décisions
les vaccinations sont indispensables et
cette loi vise à augmenter le nombre
d'inoculation parmi ceux qui ont
l'impression de ne pas avoir besoin de
se faire vacciner
concrètement certains organismes publics
comme les municipalités pourront
contacter les personnes non vaccinées
pour les encourager à sauter le pas un
texte qui poursuit la politique
offensive du gouvernement face au co
lead designer le pays avait déjà mis en
place un système réservant l'accès à
certains lieux publics aux détenteurs
d'un badge vert à savoir ce qu'ils ont
reçu la seconde dose du vaccin ou qui
ont récupéré de la maladie une loi
liberticide
aux yeux de l'opposition laquelle
dénonce une atteinte à la vie privée
ces informations appartiennent aux
citoyens et aujourd'hui vous lorgnez
leur droit à la confidentialité sur
leurs informations médicales
officiellement valable pour une durée de
trois mois ce texte législatif pourrait
être suivi par un autre beaucoup plus
sévère le ministère de la santé pourrait
prochainement présenter une loi
proposant d'interdire aux employés
notamment ceux de la santé de
l'éducation des transports publics ou de
la sécurité
l'accès à leur lieu de travail s'ils ne
sont pas immunisés guéri ou s'ils ne se
font pas tester régulièrement
une perspective qui a poussé hier
plusieurs dizaines d'israéliens
à manifester leur mécontentement à tel
aviv